i'm going to make a bold prediction
you probably don't like people stealing
your identity which allows them to steal
your money or maybe tell the whole
universe what you're up to and being
able to track you and your family and
compromise your security these don't
feel like good things
and so if that is true of you it's true
of me i don't like any of those things i
want to keep my private information
private then you should care about data
security and that's what we're going to
do in this unit you're going to learn a
lot about personally identifiable
information your name is one example but
also things like your social security
number or things that are indirectly
personally identifiable like your
address or your phone number why that's
important
and then we're going to learn the ways
that people are going to try to get a
hold of it and why they want to get a
hold of it because
they might want to misrepresent you or
or publish things about you on the
internet or control your presence on the
internet or steal money from you or from
others
that you care about
and then we're going to learn about ways
to protect from those a lot of that's
going to be behavior change on your part
to be a little bit more vigilant but
also technology ways of keeping your
data secret encrypting your data
authentication making sure that the
person who says they are who they are
are actually them
so enjoy this unit on data security it
isn't just interesting which it is
it could save you a lot of money a lot
of pain and a lot of embarrassment